so a bunch of questions for you um if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why ooh
i don't know it depends on the person is
there like well
usually it's like a uh a reason to talk
about us but we can go on to a different
question no i mean i just rev sorry it
just really depends on the person i've
done so much different genre stuff and
have done
you know so many you know low budget
independent you know whatever
kind of things and then these bigger
projects marathons like it's so funny
like the idea you couldn't get people to
watch an 18-hour movie but you could
watch 18 episodes and binge watch it you
know like so it really depends on the
person some kind of time you
got what kind of humor you're into i
feel
like that's been a big part of my
decision making film wise is have i done
it before
and um you know is it an audience maybe
that i haven't explored
and it's just type of job i'm just
trying to challenge myself and push
myself and not get too familiar some
people really lean into that you know
you can count on their laugh or a smile
or something like that 15 minutes in and
they become
that kind of actor or whatever but like
i just want to be a part of all the
genres i just want to be in all the
universes i'm in usq
marvel dc you know i'm hoping to be a
mutant one day and in star trek and then
that's it then i'm good is there a
project from your past that you wish
more people had seen you know something
that you're proud of that you want to
highlight gosh i i have to just say i
want to just appreciate on the fact that
there's been so many fans for projects
say like
joe's and the pussycats or things that
might not have necessarily hit at the
time
um but people have kept alive all these
years and and you know i think that's
really special so
now that the costume and the makeup and
everything for soka is out there have
you thought about ever like wanting to
go to a comic-con and like being it like
doing cosplay yeah
no i was talking about that i want to
play i want to be like the person who
walks around in disney takes pictures
with kids i think that'd be dope i i i
think it would be amazing yeah
like amazing
i'm really impressed by people's cosplay
though like the folks that i interact
with people get really down sometimes
with like
the details which are really really
incredible so i thought that i think
it's great i i'm a cosplayer so that's
fun
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
um i found clerks three to be more
emotional than i
how was it for you i was ugly crying
during the premiere that was just
something i gave myself over to i hadn't
seen it before so i was i had expected
it i was glad my makeup survived but
i um
you know have been wanting to see the
story for a long time not particularly
the story i didn't know that until i
read the script exactly what it's going
to look like but i've been wanting to
catch up with these characters for a
while
and uh and it was it was poignant you
know because it's not just a story
it's a reality we almost lost kevin to a
heart attack you know we wouldn't have
had this movie wouldn't have had so many
different things seeing his daughter
being a part of his storytelling so much
she would have been without her father
like you know just the what these
relationships mean to us on camera and
behind it and off um
is just
so meta and this and in a way that is
hard to describe honestly um and it just
is is um
it just felt really important and really
special and really poignant and i loved
being able to be
becky again and love her
i miss her um and
it was so special that she's so
important
that
it could
make the film automatically resonate and
like
hit it
hit a soft spot so quickly you know be
so jarring and so captivating
and such a an important storyline like
it just it was just remarkable to be a
part of a decades-long
storytelling um
in a way that just resonated so so
strongly and was so emotional it has
just so much humanity to it so
um
yeah i'm glad it really all worked it
was controversial i was nervous about it
like i've been like really anxious about
it and you did all a bunch of improv and
stuff i didn't know it was going to be
in there
you know um
and it's just it's really special it's
really amazing and it was wonderful to
see all the stuff that i didn't get to
see on the day because i wasn't filming
every day but like brian
like
that monologue he does at the end is so
powerful like he really killed that
there's their their performances in this
across the board was really really
special and just earned over a lot of
years um
so i think the fans i think the fans are
gonna
i think they're gonna really love it
what do you think uh fans of kevin smith
would be surprised to learn about like
the way he works on set if anything
um
i don't know i think he really with his
podcast and everything he really brings
people behind the scenes but it really
is so relaxed
like it is just so relaxed it's such a
well-oiled machine and he knows what he
wants he expresses it super well and
everyone's just on the same page and we
just all know what we're making and it's
so quick um
and it just is
it's just it feels super relaxed like it
just we're just hanging out
you know yeah that's i've now been on a
several of his sets it's something it's
just hard work like it's super stressful
and i'll talk to the liz destro and the
producers and you know like i get the
things that are like the location fell
through this like all the stuff the
stresses that are normal to making a
film but
i think just because he loves it so much
and and he's so good at it that it just
there's some kind of like
i don't know it just feels easy
liz destro would be like
not easy but it feels easy he makes it
really just easy so you're just having
fun which is nice
not every cell feels fun so i appreciate
that no i think a lot of people who just
watch movies don't understand what
really goes on behind the scenes of the
making of a film and how challenging it
can be
you know yeah for sure
i definitely have to ask you i am really
looking forward to your disney series um
uh like really looking forward to it um
what can have you actually started
filming i actually don't know oh yeah we
started filming on my birthday may 9th
and we're just a couple months shy of
finishing so
i know you're going to be guarded uh but
can i'm curious like what directors you
get to work with um on the series is it
similar to like the mandalorian crew or
is it more like other people stepping in
again like i don't know
i'm allowed to save any of that stuff
but
i do have to say it's um
it feels really really special like
everyone is really excited about it dave
has been wanting to tell the story for a
while
um and everyone's just really showing up
and out like a lot of blood sweat and
tears going into this and it feels like
you know what's interesting is is that
because of mando
you know
everyone's really great at making star
wars
you know
like they're just it's a different it's
a well-oiled machine in a different kind
of way you know and
there's a familiarity between all the
different departments
which is super interesting because i've
only experienced that again on like
spike lee joint or you know a few skew
universe project because there's just
such a family kind of element to it um
and that's what it feels like on set so
that's special because um
you know it's hard what we're doing and
we're
it's it's really coming together really
beautifully there's a lot of dedication
and heart going into it um and we know
we know the expectations so we're loving
it so far so i can just say we're we're
enjoying ourselves i will say that i
think that the star wars on disney play
i've seen the some of andor and um
[Music]
yeah no it's it's it's really incredible
actually
four episodes i saw um but i'm one of
the things that i love about uh what
they've been doing is using the volume
technology to help tell stories and i
just want to know if you can talk a
little bit about working with that
technology and what it's allowed you to
do or what you just you can talk a
little bit about it because it's really
impressive
no it's it's shocking it's really
remarkable what we're able to do and i
have to say it was one of the coolest
things on mando
having robert there and you know us
doing sin city on green screen
together in blue screen and like to see
where the technology has evolved to
and all of us being like 90s um
folks right like john favreau with
swingers like it's like there's this
nerdy awesome just behind the scenes
thing of it like yeah these books have
become these remarkable auteurs and like
can kind of do anything they wanted but
they're really just coming from this
independent background of just like
going
i want to make something cool i want to
do something i love this whole process i
love filmmaking and so to be able to do
something on you know they're making pre
visits and you know when he was doing
lion king and they're doing all this
stuff in virtual reality like i mean
they're really
transforming just how the whole process
is um
and it's wonderful when you're there and
the whole crew and the cast like
everybody can see it
you know we're not just like looking at
dots like we're able to really visualize
and there's a graphic on the screen
that's showing us what it's going to
look like in post already and you know
it's just it's it's it's really cool and
it feels big in the scope and broad and
outside and we're indoors like it's
it's just mind-boggling it's really it's
really cool like we're always like
really cool
i really i really can't wait to see it
and i also when you can see andor watch
it it's really easy yeah oh yeah i'm so
excited rogue one's like my favorite so
oh android's incredible you'll see um
anyway thank you so much for your time
and um thank you
awesome you too stephen
you